anciennement ville canton trappe s'est
élargi pour ce scrutin du 22 mars à deux
autres communes la verrière et l'encours
de communes ancré à gauche pour une
seule à droite mais une équation pas
aussi simple que cela
conseillère départementale sortante
soutenue par le parti socialiste jeanny
de marie se présente cette fois-ci
nouvelles règles sur la parité oblige
avec alain ajaj mehr communiste de la
verrière
mais ce dernier n'a pas reçu le soutien
de sa formation s'était pas là
l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'était la reconnaissance
des qualités de chacun pour pouvoir
porter cette cette fibre sociale auprès
auprès des gens et lui attrape en tant
que première adjointe à l'éducation
jeanine marie siège au département
depuis 2008
principal axe de campagne l'action
sociale c'est un département qui a
suffisamment de richesses pour qu'ils
s'interrogent sur la répartition de ces
richesses et qu'une partie de ses
richesses puisse être destinée au
développement et à la réponse aux
besoins qui se sont à des besoins
sociaux éducatifs ou d'aménagements ou
des besoins écologiques sur notre notre
canton pour renverser ce canton et
réaliser le grand chelem attendu par le
président sortant du conseil
départemental pierre bédier la droite
mise sur un ticket composé du maire
d'elancourt jean michel fourgous et de
sa deuxième adjointe en charge de
l'éducation
anne capio jean michel fourgous ancien
député qui ne cache pas sa velléité a
retrouvé son poste dans deux ans et qui
axe sa campagne sur le développement
économique mais aussi sur le numérique à
l'école
prenant pour exemple les réalisations
menées dans sa ville moi mon boulot
jusqu'à maintenant sur l encours des
luttes terrain avec les familles et les
enseignants nous permettent aujourd'hui
de transmettre cette expérience là aux
autres villes du département et est
également notre objectif est aussi de
faire un lien entre la pédagogie et les
apprentissages scolaires entre le
primaire et le secondaire puisque le
conseil général a bien sûr la compétence
des collèges l'encours et ce canton donc
voir un vent essayait d'être league un
exemple national avec bien sûr la zone
de saint quentin
de cette évolution de la pédagogie
française qui vous le savez trop frontal
trop magistral il faut que l'enfant
demain soit plus indépendant qu'il qu'il
qu'ils soient plus impliqués dans
l'apprentissage enfin on est en train de
transformer les méthodes d'apprentissage
reste qu une troisième liste pourrait
bien venir perturber ce duel gauche
droite nicola boem élu d'opposition à l
encours et marc ribot qui se présente
sous les couleurs de marine le pen et
entendent bien surfer sur les derniers
sondages nationaux
on alerte nos compatriotes sur leur
incapacité à gouverner notre pays nous
on offre une alternative qui je crois
aujourd'hui et crédible
on l'a montré dans les conseils
municipaux on est extrêmement comment
dire
on est extrêmement percutant on essaie
de l'être en tout cas on est parfois un
peu seul contre tous je crois que que
les français sont en attente de quelque
chose de fort qui n'arrive pas et je
pense que ça sera cette sélection
départementale sera forcément nationale
dans ces deux cantons deux autres listes
se présentent l'une porté par esther
lafitte et luc miserait au nom du front
de gauche et d'europe écologie les verts
l'autre associe sleman busan à et karima
la suède sans étiquette